for anyone looking to buy a home we have
got this one
feature that real estate pros say that
you
must have apartment therapy i love
apartment therapy
yeah it's addiction oh my god they're
like here's what you can do for 500
and it's like it's just insane apartment
therapy reports realtors say
this can actually improve your
relationship with your partner and it's
a double vanity in the bathroom experts
say it gives personal space where it
counts
and if you own your home and you want to
upgrade from a single
sink to a double they say it will
actually boost the value
of your home so nate
thoughts um this
should apply in like top level to gay
men
i'm just saying because we're hairy so
we have two two hair balls as opposed to
a hundred percent one girl
boy yeah exactly like i feel like about
two girls
yeah but it's like long beautiful hair
like men's hair is all like weird and
curly and
yeah i don't know it's gross yeah i miss
the stubble you're not going to miss it
when you're living in alice and johnny's
dog room so
i'm not so i think what i
what what i would say i'm not sure if i
buy
that it's such a massive real estate
value thing i think
most people when they go into a main
bathroom we say maine not master any
longer obviously but i like that
um when they go into the main bathroom
it's sort of a bit of an expectation
that there's a double vanity and i do
think if you have the opportunity
because you're renovating your bathroom
already or you're trying to
make those decisions then why wouldn't
you do something that could add value
but um you know people are disgusting
like get them away from me in the
morning
yeah i don't want to see anybody's q-tip
i don't need to i don't even like
looking at people's shampoo
any random q-tip is to like gag
100 um here's what word you just used
which is exactly where
i get my feathers ruffled there's an
expectation that there's a double sink
nothing peeves me more than a double
sink
i'm a single woman i don't need the
double sink
i don't want the double sink and also
guess what all that
extra space i could lay out more product
where am i putting it in the bowl
i hate double sinks you really need
person i don't want it and by the way if
i'm really making out with someone guess
what we can put our faces together and
brush our teeth together too it's not
like
we can't brush our teeth together what
yeah and yeah yeah yeah yeah shower
we're going to breakfast now i sound
like
i get it i could totally hook up with
somebody and still not need to see them
flossing
and it could be great it could be out
see i'm just saying like there's
some reasons like i don't need to see
their mouthwash spit
like i i'd like to look to know that
they used it before we hook up
but you know even jeremiah i always kind
of like track what he's done in the
bathroom
but he he he leaves i thought that's
true
for him yeah he's listen we've learned
to love all parts of each other how's
that
um no but the truth is i think i'm for
it and i don't think it
i have to disagree with you i don't
think it's assumptive we can agree to
disagree
nothing peeves me off more um all right
nate you have a story go
all right so next up a new survey of
homebuyers says
people can be very superstitious when
buying a new home
domino reports that the lending tree
survey found 38 percent of people 38
decided against buying a home based on a
superstition
or they got a bad vibe or they learned
something bad had happened in the home
or the street number was unlucky
and 39 one percent more
of people refused to live next to a
cemetery but almost
half said that they would blow their
budget on a house
if it had a lucky door number drew
would you live next to a gravestone
[Laughter]
you know i first auditioned for
poltergeist
before i auditioned for e.t and that
movie really did a number on me
i mean i did a number on me and i wasn't
in it
yeah i was like i grew up in that pet
cemetery
poltergeist era and it's like all horror
movies start with like living on a
graveyard
100 and then there's always like also a
van with a sliding side door by the way
oh my god
dad actually i just got like i was like
oh my god yes
vans scare the crap out of me um how
about a van
in a cemetery with a clown driving
exactly totally
frankie my youngest daughter i just
found her new screensaver it's
it no oh come on she loves
clowns especially the creepier the
better no
i know i yeah i know well i would never
live next to a cemetery but i would
i have not bought a house because i got
a bad vibe and i don't know if the vibe
was an aesthetic vibe and i didn't think
i could
transform the space but i i
definitely i i'm afraid of
everything really anything and
everything like you had to take my van
you had to one-up me with a clown
driving
i now need therapy from just sitting
right this chair with you for five
minutes
i don't like things that go bump in the
night i don't like i like cameras i like
lights like that you know i like the
backyard to look like cape canaveral
when i'm sleeping right right right
right right
i don't even know what a lucky number
versus an unlucky number like i love
elevators with a 13th floor it's a big
thing for me i've always wanted to do
like a study on
elevators that were like screw it yeah
screw the superstition we're having a
13th
floor i love my lucky number is 22
my birthday is february 22nd so i'm 222.
if an address was 222 i'd be like
next year it's going to be 2 22 22. oh
i know i'm really excited i hope all
this covid is like over
because that really that really warrants
like an amazing party
it feels like it's called for a
celebration
you